everyone for care about everyone they're
gonna die
places on earth X the two night
crossover event starts Monday November
27th on the CW
hey everybody so they just dropped a
whole bunch of teasers for the four-way
crossover so I'm going to break that
down but I also made my arrow episode 6
video so I'll do that too but we'll
start with a crossover stuff first
because that's what everybody's freaking
out about so if you're just finding me
for the first time be sure to subscribe
to get everything I'll explain what the
schedule is for the next couple of
episodes at the end of the video - and
there is a new round of that flash ring
giveaway starting with the big stuff
first we get a better look at the evil
versions of the characters so we have
reverse flash Tom Cavanagh or called the
Blitzen flash of this earth / girl and
the evil version of Oliver whatever his
actual name is going to be so this is
their sort of evil team-up
we see the good characters the Ray the
resistance of this earth so that
explains where his character comes from
there's also a bunch of wedding pictures
obviously that's the first part of the
crossover then there's the invasion with
all these stormtroopers capturing them
it looks like they capture Felicity and
iris and take them back to their version
of STAR Labs the Blitz and flash giving
Felicity the angry helicopter treatment
it looks like they're trying to perform
some sort of experiment so maybe they're
trying to combine universes or do some
grand cosmic thing it sounds like it's
going to be much worse than just try to
kill all the people on this earth but I
just love some of these costumes it's
the first HD look we've had at some of
these evil versions of the characters
the funny thing about this is that it's
them standing shoulder to shoulder it's
still not all of the characters that are
part of the crossover because there's no
firestorm you don't see killer frost in
here there's no Harrison wells so
obviously there's gonna be a bunch of
big fight scenes this just seems like
it's gonna be one of the climactic ones
so they didn't say which episode in
particular this is from because remember
it's four separate episodes on two
nights you get a better look at killer
frost comic book costume and obviously
citizen colds costume we know that he's
probably not going to be coming back for
a little while after this big crossover
so maybe he goes out in some ambiguous
blaze of glory just ambiguous enough to
make you wonder whether or not he's
still alive but the way they kill
characters and bring them back in the
arrowverse gets really convoluted so
with Captain Cold comes back after this
I'm just expecting him to be a different
version of the character but you also
get your first look at the live action
version of the Ray so he has a crazy
light-based powers and really the rest
of these pictures just show you them on
the Waverider getting ready for some big
encounter so this seems like it's one of
the later episodes of the crossover
maybe even the legends of tomorrow
episode and that will be the final
episode obviously there are a lot of
characters that'll be in the crossover
that don't appear anywhere in these
pictures so just because you don't spot
somebody doesn't mean they're not around
but what'll probably happen is is
they'll release another trailer next
Monday or sometime early next week
because we are getting really close so
whenever that happens I'll post a new
video about it but just leave all your
questions in the comments below
moving into arrow Deathstroke stuff
probably one of the best episodes in a
long time so I'm gonna do this a little
bit differently than I would normally do
a top 10 episode video but I'll start
with all the Deathstroke storyline and
Easter eggs then I'll do the Richard
Dragons stuff but the whole idea here is
that they want to leave the Deathstroke
character in a place where he can still
be doing stuff in the arrowverse whether
or not they're actually able to bring
him on the show so obviously you know
that there's a Deathstroke movie that's
going to be happening I don't want to do
spoilers for Justice League yet but
there is some stuff in that movie that
explains a little bit about what's going
to be going on but they did that really
cool reverse Star Wars narrative where
Deathstroke the Darth Vader of this
equation is trying to save his son Luke
Skywalker like imagine Star Wars if it
was the other way around Luke Skywalker
redeems Darth Vader but what if Darth
Vader was the one trying to redeem Luke
Skywalker
so Manu Bennett's performance was great
I loved his crazy eyes like when he's
reacting to stuff like holy [ __ ] the
first time you see shadow in the
flashbacks where she starts appearing to
him again and he spins around probably
one of the best scenes in the episode
but we get to see the origin of the
modern Deathstroke costume that's our
new prototype should be ready in less
than a year just to explain the
flashback timeline so what happens is
you start seven years ago they basically
found him washed up on the Philippines
so imagine the season 2 finale in the
flashbacks where Oliver pokes his eye
out and then everything blows up in
Slade things that Oliver said Oliver
thinks that Slade is dead and they both
go about their business until you see
Deathstroke resurface in this scene
during the second half of arrow season
two in present day so the way
Deathstroke explained it is is that
after the Amazo blew up the mirakuru
allowed him to survive the ocean swim
that it took to get all the way to the
Philippines that's where he was found
they brought him to this hospital so
from start to finish in these scenes
it's about two years like right before
he heads to Starling city to start
harassing Oliver like where he kills all
of the other people that he's training
with there takes the suit when he's in
the hospital was around the time that
Oliver was leaving Hong Kong in making
his way back to the island then once
Deathstroke starts to go crazy and
hallucinate shadow again over that
period of time that's when Oliver was
doing the Bratva flashbacks so the funny
thing is is that while Slade has been
spending all this time with his son
training slowly going crazy
Oliver has actually left and come back
to the island multiple times because
remember he left and went to Hong Kong
then he came back for all the
Constantine stuff the Taiana stuff that
happened during the season four
flashbacks
then he left to go to Russia to do the
brought bus stuff then came back for the
end of the season five flashbacks so
like he's just been bouncing back and
forth between the island wall Slade has
slowly been going nuts
but then the flashbacks end with that
broadcast from the pilot episode like
they literally cut and pasted that from
the pilot which is why I think the
flashbacks worked so well because you
remember watching all those season 1
season 2 scenes where they're fighting
Slade starts going crazy so just in
general I'm hoping that however many
more seasons arrow goes they're able to
do their flashbacks like this where you
bring a character like Roy back in the
flashbacks for him filling the gaps
about what he's been doing this whole
time but you can also have him flashback
to moments from season 1 season 2 season
3 the big universe building moment at
the end is when Joe reveals that Grant
Wilson exists you have another son that
mother never told you about
so we officially now have Grant Wilson
ravager on the TV show but where the TV
show has done is it's changed the order
in which Deathstroke's children have
been born so obviously we haven't heard
about rose Wilson yet we only know about
grant and Jo in the comics grant Wilson
is the oldest he becomes the first
version of ravager and obviously what
the TV show sounds like it's doing is
it's gradually turning Joseph into the
Ravager character that Grant
Wilson was in the comics maybe we'll see
that future version of grant again that
we saw on legends of tomorrow
moving into the richard dragon stuff if
you're not familiar he's a big comic
book character there been a couple
different versions of him in the comics
there's the classic version who's more
of an iron fist style character he's
like a kung-fu master that trains people
he's white the new 52 version is called
Ricardo Diaz jr. he's a John Diggle
villain from the Green Arrow comics so
they're actually doing a very comic book
accurate version of the character
specific to the new 52 comics but the
twist with this version of the comic
book character is is that he takes the
name richard dragon after he kills the
person that had the name previously so
he wasn't always called that his name
has always been Ricardo Diaz jr. he's
the son of a drug dealer from Star City
that was killed by John Diggle so he's
seeking his revenge against Diggle
so the minor tweak to the TV show
version is that he was a drug dealer a
member of the scorpions gang when the
glades sort of blew up in the first
couple of seasons got thrown in prison
then somehow was able to blackmail or
kill enough people to get the State
Department to let him out and then
basically killed anyone associated with
his past so all the paper trail anybody
that booked him all the law enforcement
officials the whole thing with a Diggle
steroids plot was a little weird but
they had to wrap this up sooner rather
than later so I'm happy that he came
clean to everybody but it's basically
the end of the Diggle led team arrow
because Oliver's back now and obviously
he can't get the meds anymore so he's
still gonna have the shakes so Oliver's
gonna have to put the costume back on
but as far as we know
Richard dragon on the TV show is just
like a really big drug kingpin he has no
greater ambition so we'll see if there's
anything bigger behind that or if
there's any intersection with the Kate
and James villain plot because right now
you have like a couple of different
villains on the TV show and they have
nothing to do with each other
but what's gonna happen next is is
because next week is Thanksgiving the
episode is titled Thanksgiving and
that'll be the lead in to the four-way
crossover because right after that that
next week will be the first night of the
crossover so you literally go from
Thursday to Monday to like everything
exploding and everyone's faces across
the multiverse but there is a new route
of that blast ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
I'll announce a new winner when I post
my next Justice League video because
there's still a ton of Justice League
stuff we need to talk about my next one
will be my spoiler review that will post
on Saturday then I'll start doing Easter
eggs you can click here for brand new
flash and that Wonder Woman crossover
scene and you can click here for my
brand new Black Panther trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight